THAT PROBABLY IF I HAD TO BET
WON’T BE COMING.
HERE WITH MORE WENDY RITTENHOUSE
IS WITH US.
I AM SURE THIS IS A HARD TIME
FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILY.
I WANT TO TAKE THIS AUDIENCE
BACK TO YESTERDAY WHEN YOUR SON
WAS TESTING AND HE HAD A TOUGH
TIME.
LET’S PLAY THIS.
>> I WAS CORNERED IN FRONT OF ME
WITH MR. ZIMINSKI.
AND THERE WERE --
[VOICE BREAKING].
[SOBBING].
THERE WERE PEOPLE --
[VOICE BREAKING].
[SOBBING]
[SOBBING].
[INAUDIBLE].
>> WE WILL TAKE A BREAK.
>> Sean: I WATCHED THAT.
I READ PEOPLE PRETTY WELL.
DONE IT MY WHOLE LIFE.
THAT SEEMED LIKE A CLASSIC PANIC
ATTACK THAT WE WERE WITNESSING
ON THE STAND.
THAT’S YOUR SON.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE YOU FEEL?
>> [SILENCE].
I JUST BREAKDOWN WITH KYLE
CRYING LIKE THAT.
IT MADE ME FEEL HEART BROKEN AND
SAD.
I WANTED TO JUST GO UP THERE AND
HUG HIM AND TELL HIM IT WOULD BE
OKAY.
>> WHEN THE CANDIDATE FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND OTHER ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT
DON’T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT YOUR
SON REFER TO HIM AS A WHITE
SUPREMACIST, I HAVE YET TO SEE
ANY EVIDENCE THAT HE IS SUCH
A PERSON.
WHEN PROMINENT PEOPLE SAY THAT,
HOW DID THAT IMPACT YOU AND
IMPACT HIM?
>> WHEN I SAW, AFTERWARDS OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE.
I WAS IN SHOCK.
I WAS ANGRY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN DON’T KNOW MY
SON.
WHATSOEVER.
HE IS NOT A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
HE IS NOT A RACIST.
HE DID THAT FOR THE VOTES.
I WAS SO ANGRY FOR A WHILE AT
HIM AND WHAT HE DID TO MY SON.
HE DEFAMED HIM.
>> Sean: LET’S GO BACK TO THAT
NIGHT AND ROLL THIS VIDEOTAPE
PUT TOGETHER BY YOUR SON’S
FORMER ATTORNEY.
YOU SEE YOUR SON RUNNING AND
A CROWD OF PEOPLE RACING TO
CATCH UP TO HIM.
THE FIRST OPINION KNOCKS OFF HIS
HAT.
HE IS ON THE GROUND WANT THEN
THIS PICTURE OF AN INDIVIDUAL
WITH HIS LEG UP ABOUT TO POUND
HIS LEG INTO HIS FACE INTO THE
CEMENT.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE SHOOTINGS.
WHAT DO YOU SEE THERE?
>> I SEE THIS MAN TRYING TO KICK
MY SON IN THE FACE.
I WAS SCARED.
I WAS FRIGHTENED.
I THOUGHT MY SON WAS GOING TO
DIE THAT NIGHT.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU SEE THE TAPE
AND YOU HEARD WITNESSES TESTIFY
THAT HE WAS TRYING TO DEESCALATE
THE SITUATION THERE, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE TAPE AND THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY AND THEN THE
PROSECUTION BRINGS ON THEIR STAR
WITNESS WHO GOT SHOT BY YOUR
SON.
THAT STAR WITNESS ADMITTED ON
THE STAND UNDER OATH HE AIMED
A LOADED GUN AT YOUR SON BEFORE
YOUR SON SHOT HIM.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A CLASSIC CASE
OF SELF-DEFENSE.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WHEN I LOOK AT THE VIDEO WITH
THAT GUY POINTING THE GUN TO MY
SON’S HEAD, I THOUGHT HE WAS
GOING TO DIE.
[CRYING].
HE POINTED HIS GUN AT HIS HEAD.
[VOICE BREAKING].
IT TOOK A LONG TIME JUST TO
GRASP THAT HE WAS ALIVE.
KNOWING HE IS WITH ME, I AM
GRATEFUL.
I AM RELIEVED HE IS OKAY, BUT HE
HAS A LOT OF HEALING TO DO.
BECAUSE HE DOES HAVE NIGHTMARES
FROM THIS.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THE JUDGE WHO WHAT HAS BEEN
HARSH AGAINST THE PROSECUTION.
THEY MAY BE OVER THE BORDER
LINE.
IT BETTER STOP.
I WAS ASTONISHED WHEN YOU BEGAN
YOUR EXAMINATION BY COMMENTING
ON POST-ARREST SILENCE.
THAT’S BEEN THE BASIC LAW IN
THIS COUNTRY FOR 50 YEARS.
DON’T GET BRAZEN WITH ME.
YOU KNEW ATTORNEYS CAN’T GO INTO
THESE AREAS.
DO YOU THINK YOUR SON AS
RECEIVED A FAIR TRIAL?
>> THE JUDGE IS VERY FAIR.
PEOPLE THAT I TALK TO WHO LIVED
IN KENOSHA ALL THEIR LIVES TOLD
ME JUDGE SCHROEDER AND A FAIR
JUDGE AND DOESN’T ALLOW NO
NONSENSE IN HIS COURTROOM.
>> Sean: NOBODY KNOWS WHAT
A JURY WILL DO.
I AM NOT ASKING SPECIFICALLY FOR
THEIR REACTION.
A SCALE OF 1 TO 10 HOW SERIOUSLY
DO YOU BELIEVE THEY ARE TAKING
THIS CASE BECAUSE THEY HOLD YOUR
SON’S LIFE IN YOUR HANDS?
>> YES, THEY DO.
THE JURY HAVE BEEN KEEPING
A CLOSE EYE ON EVERY EVIDENCE
AND EVERY TESTIMONY.
THEY ARE PAYING GOOD ATTENTION
WHAT IS SAID THAT IS THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: THIS LAST QUESTION.
YOUR SON WAS A LIFEGUARD AND
STATED REASON WAS TO HELP
PROTECT STORES AND HELP ON THE
MEDICAL FRONT.
HAVE YOU AND YOUR SON DISCUSSED
WHETHER OR NOT IF HE HAD TO DO
IT OVER AGAIN HE WOULD GO INTO
A SITUATION LIKE THAT?
>> WITH KYLE, I KNOW HIM.
HE WOULD PROBABLY DO IT AGAIN.
THAT’S THE TYPE OF PERSON HE IS.
HE ALWAYS WANTS TO HELP PEOPLE.
EVEN SINCE HE WAS A LITTLE BOY,
ALL HE WANTED TO DO WAS HELP
PEOPLE.
IT DIDN’T MATTER IF IT WAS
RAKING LEAVES FOR THE NORTH
CAROLINAS OR TALKING TO THEM OR
JUST BEING GOOFY.
THAT’S HOW I RAISED HIM IS TO
HELP PEOPLE.
>> Sean: WENDY, I LEARNED IN 33
YEARS OF BROADCASTING NOT TO
PREDICT A JURY OUTCOME.
I THINK THE PROSECUTION PUT ON